hello i'm matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
i can remember to the weekend when i was
a young boy that i discovered how cool
persuasion can be
my mother had instructed my brother and
me to create garage sale signs but we
needed to misspell them
she instructed us to insert a b in the
middle of the word garage
so unlike all of our neighbors that
weekend who are having garage sales we
were having a garbage sale
at the end of the day we sold more stuff
than anyone else
my mother proudly asserts that it was
the garbage that drew people's attention
to our sign and thus to our garage sale
now i of course upon reflection think
people just thought we were stupid and
they'd get better deals
regardless i learned that day that
persuasion and how you influence people
can be affected by the language and
communication you use
and when you think about it much of our
communication involves trying to
influence others
if you're trying to pitch a new idea get
support for an important cause or even
get your kids to eat their vegetables
then persuasion is the name of the game
today i'm really excited to be joined by
zac tormula the lawrence w lane
professor of behavioral science and
marketing at the gsb
zach teaches popular courses of
persuasion and attitude
and his research provides valuable
insights into how to be more effective
in your influence
welcome zach thanks a lot for having me
matt yeah so let's go ahead and get
started i'd like to ask you to share how
you think about persuasion what's your
definition uh yeah that's a i think a
great starting point um
in general i think of persuasion in
terms of the efforts we make to shape or
shift people in their attitudes
um their beliefs and behaviors so
it's not really about you know tricking
people into doing what you want or into
buying your product and it's definitely
not about forcing people to act or
behave in a certain way
it's more about understanding the
factors that kind of
actually engage people or open them up
to your ideas and input and maybe get
them to see something some issue or some
entity a little bit differently so
that's that's how i think about it
you've studied lots of important
features of persuasive communication
that can help us to become more
effective to begin you've looked at the
impact of engagement on persuasion how
does engagement influence persuasion and
what are some of the things we can do to
increase engagement engagement basically
refers to how much attention people pay
to you and your message so it's it's a
way of thinking about how interested
they are in it
how deeply people will think about it
and
it's important because engagement
facilitates your message's impact so you
could have a great message or argument
or
a compelling say candidate or offer but
if people aren't willing to attend to
that or think about it they're going to
miss it you know you're not going to
reach them and so engagement is really
about getting people to pay attention to
what you have to say
and uh not surprisingly you know you can
have more impact when they're doing that
and that's got to be really hard zack in
this day and age where people are
constantly bombarded with information
just getting people to pay attention is
hard
yeah and the way the way i think about
it is that
in in
situations where it's harder to get
people to pay attention because they're
bombarded and distracted and all these
kinds of things
it's all the more important to know what
the research shows about building
engagement so our ability to engage
people will be enhanced by knowing what
the techniques are and those techniques
become
more and more important you know the
less
focused people are so share with us what
are some of the techniques i'm i'm dying
to learn something because i've got two
teenagers at home and this will this
will help i hope
yeah well good luck report back to me
that's a hard audience but um
but yeah so in my research and teaching
i i usually emphasize a few core
principles and so one of one of the big
ones is that from the outset you have to
make it clear that your message is
important
and um one of the best ways to make it
clear that your message is important is
by establishing that it's relevant to to
your audience and
um you know there's a side of relevance
that's super intuitive that you know
people pay more attention to things that
are personally relevant to them like
that's not surprising at all but there
are some handy techniques you can use to
establish that um so for example you can
establish relevance
by communicating physical and temporal
proximity um so those are sort of
technical terms that i use to talk about
this but what that really means is that
you're talking about things that are
um
they're urgent they're immediate they're
happening here and now so physical temp
uh physical proximity refers to things
that are around you around your audience
so in your community for example
and temporal proximity means it's soon
or now or current um that sort of thing
and so if you can let your audience know
or communicate that the issue at hand
whatever it is you're talking about
is
relevant because it's happening now it's
happening soon it's happening here or
nearby those kinds of things
they'll generally pay a lot more
attention to it they'll find it to be
more important to them personally and
then they'll get more engaged
so that's a big one
uh
another another big one that we could
highlight here is that if you let your
audience know at the outset of your
message that you're going to be asking
for their opinion or input or asking
them to make a decision of some sort
they'll generally pay a lot more
attention to you so
you know if if following your message
you'll be asking your audience to weigh
in in some way or to make some kind of
decision or to vote or to do anything
like that
let them know up front people pay much
more attention when they know their
input or perspective will be requested
or invited at the end
those tips for engagement zack are
really helpful do you have any more
rapid fire advice for getting people
engaged
yeah sure so um off the top of my head
here here are a few ideas um one thing
is use the word you when you address
your audience as you using the second
person they tend to perk up and tune in
a little bit so that's one
asking questions is another useful
device so rather than making a
declarative statement at the outset of
your pitch if you ask your audience a
question that tends to increase their
engagement
you can also increase engagement by
referencing change so for instance if i
tell you that the guidelines around some
health behavior have recently changed
that would cause you to perk up you want
to know what the ins what the
information is and you'll get more more
engaged and think more carefully so
those are a few off the top of my head
you know say you ask questions reference
change that causes a sort of spike and
an engagement that can be useful in
persuasion wow taken together that's a
really great tool kit for getting people
to pay attention and be engaged i know
something else that you've done some
research in is you've looked at the role
of certainty and uncertainty and how
they play in persuasion can you tell us
about this and how we can
craft messages to take advantage of both
certainty and uncertainty
sure yeah certain certainty is a big one
it's something i've spent a lot of time
thinking about and a lot of my research
has has focused around that
so the the
theme with the certainty
focused strategies is that when you know
people are with you in in in principle
they're on board or they have the belief
or attitude or opinion you want them to
um try to build up their certainty and
that can be the thing that sort of
transforms them from liking your idea to
acting on that buying it recommending it
and so on so it's really about
reinforcing that position they already
have and strengthening it
that's right it's yeah in fact i think a
lot of a lot of it is about
strengthening it so we think about
certainty as a kind of attitude strength
you know like just like a muscle can be
strengthened so can our beliefs and
attitudes and opinions
and and um and then there are specific
techniques that have been shown to
help boost a person's feeling of
certainty
so for example once you know somebody's
on board with your position
try to help communicate to them that
other people are as well the the more
consensus people perceive for their own
views the more certain they tend to feel
about those views so if you ask me about
my opinion towards something and then i
give it to you and you can tell me that
89 of the people you've asked you know
have a similar opinion to mine then i
start to feel like oh i really got it
right like that that sense of being in
the majority gives me a kind of social
validation that makes me feel like my
assessment was accurate or correct so
that's that's one of the things you can
do excellent and and so tell us about
uncertainty how does that work
yeah so uncertainty um
is it's actually about getting
engagement so it goes it goes back to
the engagement um question in a way but
but uncertainty the idea there is that
although certainty is a good way to kind
of convert an attitude into action
uncertainty is better at getting people
to want more information or to think
about something and so if you can create
moments of uncertainty or moments of
doubt or wonder in your message that can
make people feel curious you know they
start thinking something like
um oh i wonder what's going on here or
why did he say that or what was she
gonna say there you know
when
people start to be curious and want more
information when they have some
uncertainty
and so there are ways that you can kind
of trigger or induce a little bit of
uncertainty
as a way to sort of capitalize on that
you know you can get to get people
pulled in and more interested in the
information that you have uh
often you know when people set out to
influence others they focus on the
promoting messages all the reasons
somebody should do or think something
however there are often strong
restraining or resistance forces that
come to play that that might prevent the
adoption of whatever it is you're trying
to persuade people towards i'll never
forget you know i study communication my
wife's got a phd in psychology and we
could not for the life of us get our
kids to eat their vegetables when they
were younger and the reason was not that
our messages were bad you know
you'll grow up strong your friends and
sports heroes do it it's they didn't
like the way they looked or tasted and
it wasn't until we changed the thing
that was restraining it that we actually
got them to actually enjoy eating
vegetables i know you've done some
research into ways to manage resistance
can you share some of the best practices
you've been covered
yeah sure well you know it i have done
some some work on resistance and in
general there's a healthy amount of
research on this topic that kind of
highlights the ways you can sidestep or
dampen a person's resistance if you
suspect that's coming um
so some of the things that have been
found not just this isn't just by me but
by other people who work on these topics
is that um you when you're suspecting
resistance so let's say that you have an
audience um or a target and you you know
they tend to be resistant or they they
tend to be skeptical or reactant to
whatever you say they're contrarian
those kinds of folks
um taking a less forceful more
cooperative tone or using more
cooperative language can be effective so
using words like we
us you know together as a team you know
things like that that sort of
create a common in-group we're all on
the same team here we're all in the same
group that tends to open people up
people are generally much more open to
in-group members than out group members
and so you know using cooperative
non-forceful language can help with that
so inclusive language makes people feel
part of the same team and that opens
them up
it helps as long as it's plausible and
so you know there would be cases where
you try that and people are thinking are
you crazy you know we're not in the same
group you know like people who are so
far apart or divided but as long as it's
plausible so somebody who you who you do
share some commonalities with or or you
are working toward a common goal with
you know that kind of thing highlighting
that and using the right kind of
language can can lower whatever
resistance might normally spike for them
so that's one thing you can do a kind of
related idea is to think about using
pro-attitudinal framing and so you know
when when you think about a person's
attitude or opinion you can usually
identify whether it's you know positive
or negative on some topic they're
favorable or unfavorable
a pro-attitudinal message
is a message that's on the same side of
an issue so if that per if someone's
positive it's also positive not negative
counter-attitudinal means it's on the
opposite side and so
sometimes when you're about to disagree
with a person which can be a situation
that triggers a lot of resistance you
have a decision to make sure you know
what should your argument be let's say
that you're making a job a hiring
decision with a colleague at work and
they want to hire a particular candidate
who you think is terrible
you could decide to say no i disagree
with that with that idea that person's
terrible but that's a really
counter-attitudinal position which can
trigger some resistance you know if
somebody
is feeling resistant that's not going to
convince them
a softer approach is to use a pro
attitude message so maybe they think
this this potential hire would be great
and you could say something like
um they're pretty good you know i see
some of the good qualities there but i
also have some concerns or i see some
limitations as well
and so it's it's likely that that kind
of message triggers less resistance in
your colleague because you're on the
same side of the issue just not as far
along as them
and so if you if you can identify some
of those things that are good maybe
starting by pointing that out you know i
yeah i see some of the benefits to that
particular candidate some of their
unique attributes
but i have some concerns people are less
resistant it kind of it sounds like
you're on the same side they become more
receptive to you right i i really like
that approach because it it seems that
it reduces to the defensiveness that
comes with resistance so the person at
least stays engaged and is willing to
have the conversation versus shutting
off altogether
that's right i think and anytime you're
thinking about resistance and how to
combat it you're really thinking about
defensiveness you know how can you make
people feel less defensive uh less
threatened by your message that you're
not gonna you're not trying to say
they're wrong or they're stupid or you
know something like that
um
so taking a more open agreeable
um inclusive and cooperative type
approach with with people generally
lowers their resistance and and then you
have a chance at least there's some
wiggle room it's still hard to persuade
people who are feeling resistant but you
might be able to you know just move them
a little bit and that little bit might
be just enough to accomplish the goal
that you had you don't always need to
flip people you know
you love that candidate i want you to
hate them i don't really need that i
just need you to
like them less and then you won't want
to hire them anymore and so keeping that
in mind usually you can have more
success with little movements baby steps
you know and and sometimes those can
have it have a big impact i think that's
a really important point that many of us
walk into our persuasive messaging and
think it's all or nothing when in fact
it's really a continuum in a little
movement might buy you something in the
short term or long term and i think
that's important for people to keep in
mind
yeah i'm a huge fan of um little
movements you know like when you think
about persuasion that yeah little
just remembering that softening a
person's position can can have a big
outcome is really important it's it's
often easier to accomplish and can be
just as effective for accomplishing your
goal
so before we end i like to ask the same
three questions of everybody i chat with
so i hope you're uh willing to answer
these questions okay let's do it all
right so if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
be confident but also open and humble
let me see be confident but also i think
you're close enough i got it yeah so be
confident but also open and humble
something like that and it's that's not
really advice that i got from any one
person right but more like an amalgam of
insight that was passed on to me by you
know from different sources so question
number two who is a communicator that
you admire and why
um that's a good one uh the um my
communicator at least top of mind right
now is steve kerr coach of the golden
state warriors um yeah yeah so i'm a big
basketball fan and living in the bay
area now for 13 years or so i've gotten
pretty swept up in warrior mania um so i
pay a lot of attention by default uh to
what's going on with the team and the
coach but but i really like his
communication style i think he has this
sweet spot combination that i was just
talking about in the last question that
he
presents as calm and confident but he
also
shows humility
uh he also uses humor very effectively
to sort of um diffuse a question or the
audience um
and so yeah so i'm going to say i like i
like steve kerr that i feel like he
seems in control he seems calm and
poised but also open not arrogant and
he's funny and he is uh engaging and
feels trustworthy as a result of all
that um i i'm a big fan of his too i
think you and i both share a passion for
basketball and and i think he's a great
choice as a as a good communicator to
admire so the third question is what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe from
your perspective but one would be
get your audience engaged and that is
often the first thing that you need to
attend to so if your audience isn't
interested and involved it's going to be
hard to reach them so focus on building
engagement especially early on
um
my number two thing is probably
establish your credibility and and i
don't
mean here i don't necessarily mean your
your expertise or your competence
although that's often important to do
but i mean you know this other stuff
we've been talking about so you should
convey that you're trustworthy that
you're open and receptive to divergent
views um
if you can
show that you have those kinds of
qualities that you're open to different
perspectives and can be trusted it's
it's you know easier to connect with and
reach your audience
um
and then my third thing i'd probably
return to um the importance of certainty
so once you know that you've got your
audience on your side focus on building
their certainty giving them some sense
of conviction
and confidence because that's as i
mentioned before the catalyst that can
sort of transform
you know an attitude into action you
know it transforms liking your idea or
your product to actively supporting it
buying it recommending it and those
kinds of things so
so maybe maybe that is
yeah not necessarily
the first three things but three big
things
get them engaged establish your
credibility and then boost their
certainty and conviction and you just
did a very nice job of helping me to
wrap up some of the
key takeaways from our conversation
today so i just want to end zach by
thanking you so much we are leaving with
some incredibly helpful best practices
for our persuasion
additionally i believe the insight into
influence that you've provided us with
will help us become better consumers of
the persuasion that we're exposed to and
for that i thank you as well yeah thank
you matt i really appreciate the
opportunity to talk to you today
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business
for more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb